Anheuser-Busch
is now made by my count as fourth or
fifth
response to the Dylan Mulvaney
controversy
not Bud Light in my mug not now not ever
again
not that I ever particularly cared for
Bud Light that's probably why I will not
be the greatest force in the Bud Light
boycott but people are boycotting it and
Anheuser-Busch is scared that's why
they're issuing another response again
and I I told you last week
that
they've tried a few different things
they came out and defended
picking Dylan Mulvaney as a as a sponsor
or someone that they are sponsoring that
didn't work that got a lot more backlash
then they leaked a story a senior Source
said Budweiser said that no people at
the highest levels knew about this
beforehand
this was only a rogue vice president of
marketing this is just the lower people
and this was this was reported on as
though this this word to exonerate
Anheuser-Busch I thought it was complete
BS I thought this is exactly the kind of
Claptrap that crisis Communications
Consultants cook up because it was
perfect it allowed Budweiser to wink at
the conservatives and say look we agree
with you that's that stuff that's
totally crazy we're totally on your side
we didn't know anything about this
but then it allows the pro trans people
to say well look the the younger people
at Bud Light they're pushing on the side
of social justice and
lgbtism and this is also great and we'll
just wait for those senior Executives to
age out of the company and this and then
nobody does anything
and then Bud Light gets away with it but
but like couldn't take the win or the
quasi-win so the CEOs just issued a
statement
Steven says
as the CEO of a company founded in
America's Heartland more than 165 years
ago I'm responsible for ensuring every
customer feels proud of our Brew
we're honored to be part of the fabric
of this country and hard-working
Americans and blah blah blah we never
intended to be part of a discussion that
divides people we're in the business of
bringing people together over a beer my
time serving this country taught me the
importance of accountability and the
vision on which America was founded hard
work and respect and I'm the CEO of this
Heritage in America and blah blah blah I
care deeply about this country this
company Our Brands and partners I spend
much of my time traveling across America
Okay blah blah blah moving forward I
will continue to work tirelessly to
bring great beers to customers across
our nation Brandon Whitworth
so nothing the announcement means
absolutely nothing
I didn't think the CEO should be fired
before I think he probably should be
fired now this is just such an
unbelievable mismanagement of this
crisis
it's such a mismanagement and it's such
a misreading of the moment it's such a
misreading of the issue Budweiser I
think could have gotten away with it
with just saying nothing and just taking
the hit and moving on
Budweiser also probably like a lot of
other World Companies could have just
weathered the storm by saying yeah we we
picked Dylan Mulvaney as one of our
people and I don't know next year we'll
pick some country singer and it'll be
fine
just move on keep on keeping on they
lose a bit of market cap in the short
term but then it goes right back up and
they'll be fine they could have also
weathered the storm if they came out and
said yeah we don't support the
transgender movement
where we support construction workers or
whatever they could the one thing that
wasn't going to work is what the CEO
just did
lukewarmness
middle of the road
this was the point of my speech at CPAC
it's why
the libs felt so threatened by my speech
that they had to lie about me all the
way up from a White House podium
they had to do it because the point of
the speech was there is no middle ground
on transgenderism
there are some issues where we can find
a conciliatory middle ground with the
libs tax rates would be an example of
this
you can find a middle ground on tax
rates okay the lives want to raise taxes
50 we want to cut taxes 20 all right
whatever we'll raise taxes slightly
everyone's happy ish okay fine
immigration
you can find a middle ground Libs want 3
million people a year coming into the
U.S conservatives want no people coming
into the U.S
how about we say half a million half a
million people okay fine
certain issues you can't find a middle
ground
abortion would be one of these issues
the right says we shouldn't murder
babies the left says we should murder
babies what's the middle round you're
going to literally split the baby I
don't think so that's an all or nothing
issue
and transgenderism even more so
because with abortion some
not very clearly thinking people will
say okay well we'll only permit abortion
in these cases or we'll permit abortion
up until 10 weeks but not at 11 weeks
and that that has no logic to it
whatsoever either the baby's a baby or
the baby's not a baby but sometimes
because the baby doesn't have a voice of
his own because the baby's in the womb
and he doesn't learn to speak yet the
kids don't really learn to speak until
they're like two so people ignore that
and they just they just try to put the
slaughter of children out of their heads
but on the issue of transgenderism it's
actually even clearer
because either the men are for all
intents and purposes women
or they're not
and you're going to see this very
clearly because either the women are
going to get their own bathroom
that excludes men from it we call it the
ladies room or they're not
and there are not going to be any men's
rooms in my these rooms anymore and
women are going to have to use the
bathroom next to men and little girls
are gonna have to take showers in the
locker room next to grown men
or they're not or the men are not
allowed in but there's no there is no
middle ground the moment that you allow
one transgender identifying person a man
who thinks that he's a woman into the
women's bathroom you have abolished
women's bathrooms
those are just two mutually
contradictory ideas and you have to pick
one they cannot simultaneously exist
because they contradict one another
I'm reminded of Dante in in Dante's
Inferno
there are people
who are who are sort of outside of Hell
or in the very outskirts of hell and
it's the lukewarm people because heaven
won't have them and Hell won't have them
either they're just spit out and this is
this comes from the gospels there's
people who are lukewarm they will be
spit out
they're so they're in they're in a way
more disgusting even than the sinners
because they've they've given up their
will they've given up their desire
they've ignored their intellect they've
surrendered their Humanity
that's that's what these people are
you've got to pick a side to put it
a little a little more terrestrial terms
if you stand in the middle of the road
on certain issues you will be hit by a
truck now you're seeing other beer
companies pounce on this they're
pouncing just like all the conservatives
whenever Democrats have a scandal we
pounce well other beer companies are
pouncing now Yingling which is a great
beer Yingling tweets out
nice picture of a can of Yingling lager
right in front of an American flag with
a sunrise right behind it says
Yingling the oldest brewery in America
independently owned family operated
since 1829 because we make good beer
this is really beautiful corporate shade
being thrown and it's being thrown in a
very traditionally American way this is
very waspy
the Wasps the founding stock of America
probably they're defining characteristic
is their subtlety they don't they don't
show boat they're fairly keep things
fairly bottled up very dry kind of humor
that's what you're seeing here
Yingling we're independently owned and
operated yeah we just kind of support
America and make good beer oh just what
oh what did Bud Light do oh I didn't
know I must not have heard about that
okay yeah anyway
we just make really this is this is the
way
this is the this is the best response
I've seen so far to the Bud Light
controversy Yingling's probably just
afraid that Jeremy is going to start his
own logger company they've got
Jeremy's lager they'll say no we already
do that we've already been doing that
for almost 200 years now by our beer
right now it's music Monday Baby we've
got to get to the member room segmentum
okay we have got to get to I'm finally
back in my studio I've got my trusty
iPad that will get to speak to you after
a week on the road last week where it
was a little hit or miss with the iPad
and we will be bringing to Bear our pop
culture hip-hop Maven skills to analyze
a new song this time
Mr Davies has given me a song
by Demi Lovato the show continues now
become a member of dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign